the end all be all is eliminate as many
barriers as possible in order to push
the product and the product itself is
their store their storefront and once
that product once that storefront is
inside whatever application you have
then they able to extrapolate cash from
you but other than that get worrying
about a hard way getting to your house
that's too many steps they want to
eliminate those
steps interesting I I understand the
their view of things from their St point
in what they want and how they want to
provide games but I'm speaking more
towards the actual game what the actual
Gamers want right do the gamers want
that right now is that is that something
that they want in 2024 2025 is that
something that's more valuable for like